ce qu'elle est prête j'entends pas
rencontré la tendance alors dit nous ton
sentiment
tu penses que c'est quel gouvernement
qui a créé une compagnie russe
je vais pas aller aussi loin mais je
sais que c'est quelque chose de louche
c'est certain c'est un coup d'état au
monde est en guerre c'est seebun à mener
c'est pas normal
donc c'est que ces qui pour toi vidage
tombale jetant forme à la fin c'est
dommage
hafid entend très bien en tête donc
c'est l'essentiel alors dit nous a pour
toi c'est quel gouvernement qui a créé
ce virus qu'est-ce qui se battent pour
quoi énerver
je suis très énervé est ce que l'on est
en grève à ce que beaucoup de gens
disparaissent et c'est injuste c'est un
trou d'état on est en guerre on
bactériologiques et c'est très triste
c'est très très très d'accord alors à
pizza il ya des gens qui ont été choqués
à part gilles gilles verdez qui disait
qu'il était d'accord avec toi qui
pouvait comprendre ton ton sentiment est
il atteint fin on a fait un sondage il
ya pas mal de gens aussi
voilà qui nous regardent qui était à 53
% d'accord avec le fait quoi là qu'ils
pouvaient avoir peut-être avoir d'autres
circonstances à ce qu on a viré ce que
tu comprends que des gens qui puissent
être choqués et toi quelle est ta
théorie sur le virus en fait
les séries sont parés de marée sinon ça
sert à rien mais attendait finalement
mal on ne comprend rien de ce que tunis
attend alors afida est ce que tu peux me
au diable ce qui paraît contentant bien
à l'antenne mais moi je comme normal
d'aumônerie afida quel est ton côté
dacquois j'aurai alors annoncions depuis
derrière nous sommes en bière par
technologique
c'est très triste marc était marié
saison non c'est très triste mais on a
déjà joué aux autos mal à ces dames et
mais on perd des terminaux nous sommes
en guerre bactériologique et c'est très
très triste on a oui mais c'est normal
comme tout le monde c'est vrai convient
un drame afida pourquoi est ce que tu
dis que c'est le gouvernement qui a créé
le virus pourquoi tu dis ça
tout simplement parce que quand on a des
great les connaît on a toujours trouvé
des vaccins là soudainement on trouve
rien la seule personne qui a trouvé
quelque chose c'est le docteur house qui
est un ace à marseille n'est trouvé un
vaccin à 16 euros et oumou l'ignorent et
l'amérique s'unira pour 400 millions de
la avec laboratoire johnson
ok donc c'est pas normal nous les
américains et même le moins on dépend
aujourd'hui de la chine qui va redevenir
le numéro numéro 1 de l'économie
mondiale c'est un coup d'état
on est en coup d'état et moi je n'ai pas
peur de dire ce que je ressens et la
vérifiant voilà alors afida reste avec
nous parce que yahia jean michel maire
qui devrait réagir oui j'entends très
mal ils proposent combien combien le
banquier z merzouk alors
combien merzouga je vous appelle mais
moi j'entends pack elite l'histoire
qu'est ce qu'ils disent aimer mais est
derrière toi même incident avec sa afida
alors tu dis qu est ce que tu te rends
compte que tu as une responsabilité
qu'il ya pas mal de personnes qui sont
choqués aussi parce que tu as dit voilà
après tu as des gens qui sont d'accord
avec toi mais oui d'orissa est ce qu'on
comprend pas ce qu'elle dit combat par
que lui c'est le cas le choix ouais je
suis l'arrêt sur un fil à afida ma
chérie juste je l'entends mieux afida je
crois là c'est mieux afida juste parce
que tu te rends compte qu'il ya des gens
qui peuvent viser de choqué par ce que
tu as dit ou pas oui c'est normal ils
sont bas ils sont pas au web ils sont
pas dans la restriction habite aux états
unis depuis 20 ans c'est quand même pas
normal
ok c'est très gras on est en guerre va
théologique et tout le monde le sait les
gens qui croient à un virus qui apparaît
du jour au lendemain alors qu'une
bouchée
[Musique]